when he was little
me I wanted to be a princess 2.3 to you
you wanted to be an astronaut
hello I can help you the blues to
my mother she and you the spans we
did not become what we dreamed of being
sure of judo  we're doing pretty well
you're in love and I don't know if the
beginning
I don't know it was still quite
a story since he passed to the
family it's not a sex story
nothing more and costs badly you  don't want to
hear what I'm going through
[Music]
ra post my love but wake up
because I can't do without you anymore
you wake up it's not possible you
were right
I was stupid I'm missing out on my life j  I'm
afraid that a man will turn everything upside down
it's true that I don't listen at all I don't listen well
you were right
but it's going to change I would like
them to be there to see
[Music]